i'm a woman hear me roar
i'll fire
your work
over here
[Music]
twerk
all right
which which is the world's largest ocean
uh
i'm gonna go atlantic pacific yeah you
gotta keep singing it was a 50-50 okay
uh before she married private she
married kanye west kim kardashian was
married to the nba player chris
humphries which team did he play for at
the time of their marriage
uh
i'll go with the uh
timberwolves the nets yeah the nets are
still around
jesus they're good now oh okay durant
yeah all right the woodstock music
festival of 1969 took place in which u.s
state
uh new york you got it yeah yeah
hallelujah
all right this could be a fun party game
i like it i like it one video some guy
sent in uh
making puppets of you guys
oh
this should be fun
wow this is already pretty well done
wow this is great oh my god the
creativity from you guys is
insane oh man
oh my god i love i'm gonna put this on
my my insta this is killer
can you email me that there peters
wow
it's almost south parky
i wonder i wonder if you'll be blue or
green or if i'll be blue or green
oh i'm thinking i'm blue
wow
yeah
the eyebrows sealed it
oh yeah
wow these are great
oh my god
that is killer
whoa
i mean the video and the puppets were
great that's pretty great oh wow
well done there who's that we got a name
can't read that
snuffbooks
video book video snuffbooks video thank
you snuffbooks incredible wow
well done give that guy a watch give him
a shout out check out his youtube
snuffbooks video
sounds a little dark snuffbooks
there's more to see guys join the
patreon right now at patreon.com we
might be drunk get on the after party i
think i just broke this
there you go
you get emails tell us your wrecks your
jokes your drinks we'll open boxes
you're missing out folks all the good
stuff's on the patreon tell a friend